-Guys, today's Friday.
That's usually when I catch up
with some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes
And I was running a bit behind.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I thought I could write
some out right now.
Roots, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?!
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Ariana Grande
joining "The Voice."
Although, it was scary
the other night
when her chair spun
around so fast
that her ponytail almost
took out John Legend.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whapssh!
Ksss!
-[ French accent ]
Those bitches.
[ Laughter ]
You had a bag with baguette
in it, too, didn't you,
when you were doing that?
I saw the whole thing.
-When I did that,
I had a striped shirt.
-Yep, beret.
-A beret, of course.
-A little mustache.
-Drawn on.
-Yep.
-Drawn-on mustache.
-Yep, cigarette.
-Cigatette.
-And a baguette
out of your back pocket.
-Yes, and a beret
in the other pocket.
-In case this one
fell off, yeah.
-As a gift for someone.
-I saw that all. Acting.
-You saw that in the acting?
-Yeah.
I saw that.
Just from the movement,
I could tell.
Ooh!
Oh, my gosh!
The beret just --
Wait, are you wearing
a beret, or not?
Sssss!
You put it out
in a cup of espresso.
-Correct.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
He's got some butter?
Some beurre?
Jam. Ham. Nutella.
[ Laughter ]
What is it?
Peanut butter.
You're French.
Oh, you're spreading something.
It's French bread.
French fries.
-Brie.
-[ French accent ] Mayonnaise?
Cheese.
Gruyère cheese?
-Close.
-Brie!
-Guys, guys!
Stop!
-You're a Frenchman.
You're spreading...
-Dijon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Gosh!
[ Muttering ]
-I feel like a fool.
I feel like a fool.
You're prepping the sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
-I was correcting the sandwich.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
you were just
getting ready to eat.
I thought you were
creating a sandwich.
-I was correcting the sandwich.
-You were correcting it
by putting Dijon.
-I don't work at Subway.
I'm a sandwich corrector.
-Right.
"Hey, that's wrong."
-Thanks.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Applebee's new
spooky Halloween cocktails.
Or as people everywhere put it,
"Uh,
I'm going to have
to do my own research
before I put that into my body."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm gonna have
to do my own research
before I do that, please.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, sweater weather,
or, as I like to call it,
Chris Evans season.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ Scat sings note ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
outdoor movie nights,
for combining the fun
of going to the movies
with the excitement of getting
600 mosquito bites.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Buzz ]
[ Continues buzzing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Higgins, can you not do that?
Sounds like a mosquito.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
I have something in my throat.
-Yeah.
-[ Buzz ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, laptop chargers,
for only ever coming
in two lengths --
6 inches too short,
or 6 feet too long.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a long charger.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, push pins,
for being thumb tacks
that wear top hats.
There you have it, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Those are my thank-you notes.